okay thanks everybody thanks for joining
uh I'm Fabio I work at up sorts uh and
so today we're going to be talking about
how to build uh serverless electricity
price prediction uh with python observes
and a bunch of other services
so
um as you can probably hear from my
accent I'm not from the states I'm
actually Italian
um and we have a situation in Europe
right now um kind of electricity pricing
prices are kind of to the moon so like
the idea behind it is basically just to
kind of build a model
um to predict this crisis uh and try to
be in the meantime I try to kind of look
at the at the workflow and look at how
the partners work together and how to
optimize that
um it's the system is quite
interconnected to each other
um I don't have access to like real
quality data so there's a bunch of like
open data set you can use
um I'm gonna be focusing only on uh on
this reading Swedish area uh Sweden uh
is divided into uh what was it called
four different bidding areas um so they
are independent kind of market and and
then electricity flows between the
different markets
um and obviously it's connecting
technically the rest of Europe
um it this specific talk we're going to
focusing on the bidding area number
three which is the Stockholm region and
only because kind of I live there so
that's what I'm interested on
um and the other aspect is that
obviously because it's been connected
like electricity prices in I don't know
for instance in Germany uh affect also
Audi A2 surprising in Sweden actually
um
um the nice thing about Sweden is that
the Energy Mix so the weight energy is
actually generated
um it's not really reliant on on natural
gas so we can ignore pretty much a lot
of news out there and just focus on
um on like more and more simple features
that you can manage and so that allows
us to focus more on the workflow and the
pipeline and and out of myself
okay so
um as I mentioned we want to make sure
that we uh we have um uh like a good
model but we have subset of features so
we're going to be looking at the weather
data I don't know if you've ever been in
Sweden but
um it's quite like gloomy especially
during the winter uh there is no really
a lot of sunlight that obviously has
effect behind terms of like you know if
you have solar power uh generation and
so on so forth and also in terms of
consumption uh we're gonna be looking at
a bunch of features coming from all the
features how the data was how the power
was generated and you're going to be
looking at how the power is exchanged
between different uh different flows
have different regions and also
um looking at the calendar year
obviously uh holidays and like uh
weekends Our Generation consumption is
it's lower
so if you take a traditional model and
architecture with the way you will set
it up is basically you have all your
data sources
um you have your pipelines taking data
from data sources and fitting into the
model
um and then the model is built
um there are I would say two problems
here the first one is obviously we want
to make an inference at the end we want
to be able to use this one and to be
able to use these uh this model we need
the historical data that is available in
your data sources so what was the
weather in the past couple of days
obviously as in fact uh even at depends
time and and the other the other aspect
is that all these uh pipelines going
from data sources to your model
um are somewhat connected to the model
um but you could potentially have a
bunch of different models and you might
want to reuse all those features so
um you want to you want to also
disconnect
um the data data sources and pipelines
from the model itself
right so
um how do we do that
um the basic idea here is it's kind of
split up the the single pipeline single
workflow into multiple pipelines right
um the first one is basically picking up
data from data sources and creating
features
um the output of that pipeline is
actually
um the feature store and the register in
that case acts as a as a shared buffer
um between different pipeline or like
computer bus for instance
um these are obviously executed either
can be executed in batch um in our case
it gets executed nightly that's when
data gets gets uh is available
um it can be streaming sources so that
pipeline will also be streaming
um and the different pipelines different
from here different pipelines can be
independent from each other so you might
have a pipeline looking at the weather
data and creating features out of the
weather data can be independent from the
one that creates features out of the
power generation mix essentially
the next step is obviously taking data
from the future store and creating a
model that's what that's what the
training pipeline comes into the picture
um and again the output is again put
into the into the bus as as a as a form
of model right so now
the model and the features are available
in the future store and finally we get
the inference pipeline that uses the
model uses historical data and
potentially uses the input data to make
to make predictions
so
um this is kind of the eye level
architecture and if we were to kind of
separate the different components and
building blocks for this one
um we have a section up there which is
basically the compute section where you
know all the uh computation for both the
feature Pipeline and model training
actually happens
um we have state at the bottom it's
basically all your featured data and
your model and then we have some more
compute
um on the top right for doing events
and the way we want to address this
problem is that for compute you're
pretty much flexible to use um whatever
like stack you want to use and there's a
ton of options out there uh in my case
I'm just going to be using a bunch of
their notebooks and I'm going to be
using
um GitHub action for for scheduling
um but there are a lot of like tools out
there that you can use for either
scheduling but also run the pi data
stack to basically create features and
so on and obviously they want to focus
on the on the state part
um then nobody wants to really manage
State it's quite uh cumbersome
um that's where kind of officers comes
comes in the picture to help out uh to
help out there
so the new pipeline looks something like
this
um we have always the sources here they
are collapsed
um you get your um you get your your
compute layer Computing both features
and and models so training action model
and saving them into the into the state
which is preset manager which is objects
and um in this specific case for this
specific pipeline you're gonna have seen
data we also create predictions and
store them into the feature store we're
not going to do that real time but we
pre-compute them and make them available
uh in stream League which is going to be
our our UI to display the the outcome of
the predictions
and again if you look this same
architecture before compute layer State
layer again the final compute layer for
the
um for the influence
okay so
um important we want to focus most is
actually the State Management so we're
going to look at the feature store
aspect
um the feature store aspect as the
absolutely destroys has two main API to
interact with as an API to right into
the digit store as an API to read from
the future store
um the way it works and I'm going to
show you uh in one second let me open a
notebook
oops
a is the following me so if I look up
for this one this is one of the uh one
of the pipelines that actually generates
the features for the uh the power mix
um essentially just reading a bunch of
CSV files and that's that's how they
provider makes them available uh we're
gonna be dropping a bunch of features a
bunch of columns which are not going to
be used um they are not available in the
region specific uh you can just like do
some column name manipulation uh fixing
the time format
and this is very important later on we
see and how we we deal with times and we
just create the different times
and then we're just gonna fix the the
types for the different uh for the
different uh different power sources and
eventually and the data frame look like
this this is a fundus data frame
um you have all your all your features
vertically
um and then horizontally you have
reached our
um you have the different
um power sources in in megawatts
essentially
and as you can see here I'm not doing
any normalization features you have
pretty pretty high values pretty like
spread out values
um and I come back I come back later on
on why I'm going to write PSS features
I'm not going to apply any
transformation at this stage
um and then this is where kind of like
the the objects API comes into the
picture I'm gonna create a feature group
so essentially it's a set of features
just with a bunch of metadata like name
version
um if you have descriptions
um the event time and a cover letter
what is needed
um if I want to store it online or
offline and I want to also compute um
statistics for it and then eventually
um everything that is needed essentially
take your data frame and and call the
insert method right into the into the
into the feature store
the way it's gonna get written is by
using
um this type of architecture essentially
so the data is when I land in a cafe
topic that objects manages and then the
data is gets picked up from there and
it's going to get written uh both
offline uh and online
um in case you need it like you need
online if you are doing real-time
operations in real time
um real-time predictions
um offline is mostly used for training
models but also for if you're doing
batch predictions
um that's that's something you can add
something to use your flying features
therefore
and the way then you can see that in in
the abstract UI you basically see
um all your features
um that you can have uh you will see
where things have been used
um and I'll cover in a second the
expectation part and then you get a
bunch of metadata that you can customize
uh you can also be looking at different
statistics that are computed
automatically
um different uh you know different power
sources uh you know both in terms of
like descriptive statistics but also in
terms of like um histograms but also
correlations between the different uh
between the different power sources that
the Stockholm region uses
okay so this is your feature group uh we
have many more of them uh we have I
think five or six of them
um this is what I was mentioning before
so the holidays um and the calendar uh
features power generation is the one
we're looking at the
um all the data how the electricity
flows between different regions and
looking at the weather as well and
finally we have
um these Stores Only labels which is
actually the AI ad Price so
um the price that obviously estimate uh
for tomorrow uh at like you know four in
the afternoon or any other time
essentially so that's this feature group
it just contains
um just contains my uh my labels
essentially
okay
so the next steps is I'll be is
obviously creating a model out of it I
mean jump back into SlideShare
and we're going to be using
um the second API as I mentioned the
earlier this was what it looked like
before so now we're broken down into
multiple pipelines
um those pythons are independent from
each other they can run at different
times depending on when the data source
is available and
um what what this creates
um it creates a problem in terms of like
creating a trend data set that is
somewhat aligned to us and what is
correct in time and if I yeah if I look
at
um if I look at subset of the problem
I'm going to just take two features
um and then this can be expanded through
the entire
um to the entire data set
um so I have the the weather features in
terms of like uh cloud coverage and I
want to see my label in this case for
this specific subset of the model is
going to be the solar output right
um if the pipelines run independently
and they generate events at different
times so for instance I have 10 30 11 30
and 12 30 and 12 for the weather feature
group and on the other this other side I
have at 11 12 and 13 and 1 pm
um when I'm joining the features I want
to make sure that my label feature group
has matched the most recent features
that I have available on the weather
feature group right so if you look down
at the bottom the uh four uh megawatts
gets matched with the event uh at 10 30.
so basically the 87 percent of cloud
coverage
um and the two uh five uh Watts for uh
12 and 1 pm gets matched with the 12
um uh card coverage which is 82 right so
um this basically allows us to to make
sure that even if even if the features
are generated at different rates and at
different times when you join them
together you are joining them in a point
correct time uh in a portrait fashion
um the way you would do it that in SQL
is through this massive query
um it's quite like it doesn't even slide
so it's quite like uh not clear
um but this only covers the two features
that we're looking at before right so
the actually the label and a single
feature and coming from two different
feature groups and my model has a bunch
more features coming from five different
feature groups so this query will be
much more uh significant and much more
cumbersome to write
um the way we simplify that uh in in the
API is by actually providing
um a python a funders like API which
allows us to basically say Okay I want
to select that feature from that
specific feature group and the one
selecting mean Cloud percentage from the
weather future group of joining together
and the API will automatically create
the correct
um the correct uh equity and it's
integral query and I can show you uh in
The Notebook
so I have to go into my second notebook
you can see here I'm going to select a
bunch of features a bunch of feature
groups which are my group of pictures
I'm going to turn them together starting
from my labor future groups and I'm
going to join them with the rise of the
feature groups and I'm going to exclude
some of the features that either are not
needed or they create problems and so on
so
um this is basically generate a query
object
ignore for a second this one I'll come
back in a second later and create what
we call feature view which is our our
read API will basically say give the
name
and give it the the query that I want to
use at the label so what I'm trying to
predict with this specific feature View
and I come back later on transformation
functions which of you imagine are
essentially a container for features
that um your model need right they don't
containing specific data the data comes
in the train data set
and the nice part about this API is that
allows us to generate a multiple train
data set starting from the same
interview so
um you basically have a like the schema
in the future view for that specific
model and then as your data comes in
comes into the picture like it's just
gets generated you can recreate
additional train data sets and retrain
your model over and over and over and
you are guaranteed that the schema
doesn't change so you can just like
um automate that that part essentially
but when you do that
um this can create a bunch of problems
in terms of
um in terms of uh training and semi
skills because
um when you create each other in data
set obviously the statistics of that
when they asset changes and so you have
to be careful about what you're doing in
terms of like transformation function
normalizations and stuff and stuff like
this
so the way you solve this problem in Ops
works is actually by taking care of
transformation functions so when I
register a feature view
um I assign some transformation
functions and some of them come out of
the box so like like the min max scaler
standard scalar label encoder all this
come out of the box from obstructs but
like if you are if you have your own you
can you can put you on there as well and
same transformation functions get
applied in all cases when I in generated
from this set when I am getting a
feature Vector for real-time inference
but also when I'm getting
um a patch a batch data set for uh best
prediction essentially
and if you go back to uh if you go back
to the uh to the my picture view
generation this is what these blocks
actually represent so for each of the
features that I'm going to be using I'm
going to assign a specific
transformation function and then I'm
going to register that transformation
function with the feature view that I
just created essentially and then from
there on every time I do an action on
that feature view that those
transformation function will
um will automatically be applied so I
don't have to take care of like
statistics for the train data set and
normalization and so on support
everything is hidden via the API
um for for us and so that's you know
that's what happens here essentially the
next step is basically creating a bunch
of different data sets for different
subset of window so you can specify
stats update for data inside and and
same thing happens you know if you keep
creating new print there's a person
essentially
um and those are also registered in the
future store so you can plug them in the
um in in the UI as well
and you can see a bunch of information
about where it comes from all the
different versions that you have
generated and during the asset that you
have generated and and so on and so
forth
so
we've covered the summation function and
the last thing I want to cover is about
data validation right so one of the
aspects when I want to want to make sure
that when you're using obstructs is
allows you to basically say leverage an
entire python ecosystem that that's
already available right one of the
things you want to make sure because the
features have been shared across
different projects across different
teams
um you want to make sure the future data
is actually quite the issue actually
valid and it's actually high quality
so the way you can do that in obstructs
is by using great expectation which is a
pretty popular library for doing
um data validation
and the way you can do that uh is let me
show you the notebook for that
um the way you can do that essentially
is the following so
um I have created uh expectations rate
in in the transportation you can
basically specify for instance okay the
the nuclear power generation cannot be
negative I'm same thing for solar and
I'm gonna attach this expectations to it
to my future group right so when I do
that
every time every time I write some data
into the beach store this expectations
is automatically run against my uh my my
my data mindcoming data and if the data
doesn't respect the
um
the
Expedition Street then the price is
rejected and that's what happens here so
I'm going to take up like a substantive
data frame and I'm gonna just you know
change that number to be negative I'm
going to try to write into the into the
feature group again and then this is
basically when I say I'm not going to do
that
um expectations with fails and like the
right is rejected and so I don't have
that data into the future group
um but what I do have is a report that
says your data has been like you're
trying to write some data and your data
was injected so you can see down here
you can see that at this time
um this morning I try to write something
and I uh the street was trading and you
got injected
um you can also configure the feature
group in a way that it just checks but
you know less of lesser right through so
you can change the configuration type
from strict to always and you know if
the expectation phase you can still
write it in so that's what happens here
essentially allows you to to write even
though uh even though the the
expectation was not uh complete
successfully
so that's done at the beginning
yeah yeah
now a good expectation is independent
right you just you just
um the the thing is that you just
basically attach the expectations to it
and directly into into the objects
implicating directly into obser so
um some of our users actually already
come with a bunch of expectations to it
um they don't want to go through and
write them you just take them and say
okay this basically this is what I want
my data to look like and if it doesn't
look like this
um don't don't write it into the page
store
um so yeah
okay
go back to the slides and yeah this is
basically the same in in slide format
um and again
um you can you can you can check that
um uh you can check that in the example
as well
so the final aspect is actually looking
at the prediction server uh particular
service itself uh what we want to make
sure is you want to make sure that
um the data like that once once in every
day all at once every hour
um the new data is generated and new
data has been returned to the
um being passed to the model and some
predictions are are actually
are actually
um generated and and registered with the
uh with the feature store
so again this is the same aspect so this
is I'll be at the end of the pipeline
this stage
um we're gonna use the feature store
again um this time you're not going to
store pages but we're going to be
storing actual
um actual predictions
so in the in the API let me just one
second
in the API
um so this was the the model training
aspect so
um these are different notebooks you
basically get your picture view again
and the average generate current data so
you basically just retrieve that train
data in a Honda City frame and then you
send it to
um through the model essentially
this is a tensorflow model and then you
at the end basically store that model
and in this case you store it into
obstacles but again there are a bunch of
other tools it allows you to store the
model into essentially
um yeah so the final aspect is actually
I'm using this model to to create
predictions so
um we have like a like a job in the
background that basically populates
predictions and actually upload them
uploads and as features in in the future
store so every every hour there is a new
prediction come again as you can see
here we have like a like a green button
here allows us to basically say these
are these are available online so you
can have like web applications actually
and doing that and we can have a look at
them so uh every time for every hour and
going forward we have the price
predicted
um store into the into the online video
store
and what we can do is actually we can
create a streamlined application
um that basically
um set up the connection to the feature
store retrieves that connection to
um the feature group from from obstacles
and reads the content of the online
feature store
and then uses use extremely to actually
generate
um generates like a like a web
application right so you can go back to
web search go back here and basically
just show like a simple graph streaming
it is a nice package allows you to do
all sorts of graph and visualization
um using just your python codes you can
plug it in uh you can plug it in your
your the options API directly with
simply and basically get out all sort of
uh nice nice crops and so on
um okay
slide yeah yeah so options is available
as a serverless platform so you don't
have to actually deploy anything
um you can go on up the web search API
and and register
um for for free you get a bunch of quota
and you can basically start interacting
directly through the API and both for
um managing the features but also for
serving the model that we didn't cover
in this presentation today
um to serve the modern real-time uh to a
platform for Acer so the 12 integrated
and yeah it's available uh it's
available for for free essentially
um there is another uh another course
going on
um that that we are um that we are
managing um to kind of like covers these
topics and a bunch more that allows you
to kind of learn about the introduction
of the uh of the with observes and
disabled uh ecosystem
that's it
um thank you very much and I guess you
know if you have any questions all right
thank you Fabio do we have any questions
right
hey thanks for the talk is really
informative
um just going back to the very first
slide I guess looking at the data
sources what
uh which ones are important like the
most important
for Sweden specifically the weather
um the weather is kind of like a lot
because like most of the sources come
from like most of the mg comes from like
other likely power so the way like
depending on like the uh like the the
the decision was and so on so forth you
are more or less
um you can possibly there
um but also in terms of like
um cloud coverage and like what alcohol
it was a lot of the houses in Sweden are
either through electricity
um not with with not the gas obviously
others affecting the into the into the
model itself okay thanks I have another
question too um so I saw at the end
there you used a lstm model uh have you
tried loose trees do you want to talk
about difference you saw between them no
we I no I just I just said yes okay
uh any other questions
hi uh also thank you for the talk
um so I've I've heard about hopsworks
and so far as future store I wasn't
really I hadn't really kept up in terms
of like feature releases and things like
that so I wasn't aware of model registry
um as part of it's It's offering
um can you speak to to that a little bit
more in so far as what sort of features
are are available
um and how data scientists and also on
the other side of it ml Engineers can uh
interact with that yeah yeah so um the
basic idea of adding the adding the
model registry model serving to observe
supports just to um make it so that it's
really well integrated with the uh with
the feature right so
um we put the specific effort into
making sure that like when you're
serving a model all the connections with
the online feature store all the all the
data sources from the online features
are actually
um were connected we didn't invent the
wheel there we just on the line we're
using cave serve so that's a pretty um
what that's that we'll see uh old uh I
don't know the name uh
at the old K7 they used to see all this
it's a new name for the case serving uh
for the uh look at the old names for the
K7
um for the serving platform on top of
kubernetes
um the API looks something similar to
you with trying to mimic a lot what the
community already is using for
um uh for ML flow so the way you
actually register features the register
model and so on so forth we thank you
obviously mimic that certain users um
don't have to come up with that and
continue
um like new content support
um and and that's about it I think
um you can I can give you them later on
if you come up with
um you can have it together
any other questions
yeah
yeah so the question do I typically the
question yes the question was can the
times stamp safe join be turned off
so when you create a feature group
um you can basically avoid setting this
parameter here
and that allows you to basically just
like then objects doesn't know like what
is the time of the events coming in and
so you won't generate that a specific uh
specific thing
um the time the time-based which the
time is joining the point and correct
join
um it's a little bit more expensive
operation um because obviously you have
to look at different like uh different
groups on the other future groups
um by issues of like a more uh correct
data set but if you wanna if you want to
just disable you can avoid setting up
that setting that parameter
I have one question uh this looks like a
online or like mixed batch streaming
case uh do you recommend also putting
features in the feature store when
you're still an offline experimentation
phase yeah
um I think there are two reasons for
that um the first one is
um you use it don't work but like a long
ride you always can block what I do with
a bunch of different people right and so
that allows you to basically share those
those what that work out with other
people
um the other aspect is that um there are
a bunch of features that we didn't cover
here for instance to do time travel or
like look at updates and up search so
um even though you might have like a
like a normal like a patch uh normally a
Time use case
um you can still benefit from a bunch of
those those celebrities to look back at
what was the data on maybe six months
ago or look at you know statistics and
stuff like this